Final Fantasy 15 director Hajime Tabata
wants to make you cry I'm Lucy and
welcome to this emotional gamespot news
update baked into Game Informer sabattus
answers players who invest so many hours
into a game deserve a strong ending and
that he hopes the ending to 15 leaves
players in tears I want to create a very
emotional ending to the game I want to
make as many people cry as possible
you're spending so many hours playing
the game so when I finish a game and it
ends on a sour note and it doesn't move
me it gets me disappointed at least make
me cry or give me some emotion I want to
give a moving ending for the consumers
who invest so much time another goal
that Tabata son has four Final Fantasy
15 is for it to make a similar impact on
the gaming industry that revered entry
final fantasy 7 did back in the late 90s
he explained there are some team members
that were here for seven they're taking
on the challenge of trying to exceed
that title once more which is a great
motivator for them seven sets a very
high goal for us but it serves as a good
goal it brought in new audiences sales
and more Final Fantasy 15 has been
confirmed to launch sometime this year
the square Enix will announce the exact
release date later this month so are you
prepared to cry let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games for more
on Final Fantasy keep a gamespot